hey everyone thanks for coming this is
amazing so I thought I'd try something a
little bit different today I I've given
a few workshops on numpy pandas before
that kind of thing but usually I have a
block of six hours and here we're we're
limited to two hours so what I'm gonna
do is maybe something a little bit
dangerous who's heard of pair
programming alright who's heard of mob
programming
alright mob programming you take the
payer and the other person is everyone
else I'm gonna pair program this with
all of you in the room that is why live
as we go I saw a couple of gasps over
there this is we'll see how that goes
alrighty so first of all a quick systems
check does everyone have them working
pandas install anyone who does not have
the ability to run that line all right
if you don't I recommend using condor
anaconda so if you go to continuum that
IO you can download it there it's
wonderful it's fast it's free if not pip
install pandas assuming you have Python
working and just well people yes
I prefer three these slides should work
on both but if you have the choice go
three oh let me interrupt a minute so if
there's questions I've got the
microphone here so people can hear we're
also live streaming so if you speak to
the mic then people listening to the
live stream can can hear what you're
asking and oh and if you're on the live
stream I'm going to be monitoring the
Twitter which is the at PI data Seattle
2017 so ask your questions there sorry
to interrupt
thank you already so just well the last
few people get pandas in stole I'd love
to do a quick show of hands how many
people are considered themselves
academics how many people are software
developers alright how many of you have
used pandas before okay this is where I
say I will not get offended if you'd
like to leave the room to go to a more
interesting workshop I'm going to take
you from the ground up here
okay no worries about that okay and this
is how we're gonna do it I'm gonna have
cells like this and I can type in them
and I'm just going to be able to run
them in real time cool alright I'm
assuming everyone's done that line now
so a little bit about me well while the
last few people install as was said in
the introduction I consider myself a
lapsed computational physicist I have a
PhD in computational neuroscience and
then I worked on some statistical
problems in disease transmission at
Princeton and now for just over a year
I've been a data scientist with CBRE
I also run the advanced topics on
machine learning interest group in
Seattle if anyone's based in the Seattle
area come join us
alright a little bit about the hero of
the story I love coffee I am completely
addicted to caffeine and during my PhD
this was my best friend no I worked in a
small department at the University of
Warwick and we had this wonderful
espresso machine it was wonderful for
two reasons and one was that it gave us
wonderful coffee on demand and two was
that it had this little display and then
you could hit a few buttons and it would
tell you exactly how many espressos it
had brewed to date so we wrote an
Android app we sent around to people in
the department and we said when you go
get a coffee
just interrogate the Machine and tell us
and put it into the Android app how many
coffees it's on right now and this
started at about Coffee 400 and it ended
at about maybe 27,000 this is about
standard for a math department so what
we're going to do today is we're going
to walk through an exploratory analysis
just a basic analysis of the time series
that came out of this coffee data set
it's to tell you a bit more about that
so we're going to be doing this as a way
to expose you to the pandas API pandas
is a huge package very powerful and it
can do a lot of things we're going to
try to use it in a natural way such that
by the end if you've never seen pandas
you have a good idea for how to
work with it get a feel for it slides
are available at this github link there
are two notebooks one of them is the one
I'm running through now and one of them
is called solutions and that one
contains what I'm hoping I'm going to
type at the end of this if you want to
follow along please do if you want to
skip ahead that's fine
and the pentas documentation is really
wonderful so don't hesitate to Google
things as you go I'm gonna try to fill
in the blanks about the the methods I'm
using as we go and hopefully give you a
little bit about that so this time
series database the this time series
dataset what does it look like it's
literally got a row for a timestamp 2015
October 3rd 10:00 or 4:00 in the morning
it has a number of coffee's brewed to
date 11200 11 and then it has a
contributor so when you install this
Android app it asks you for your name
the first time and that just lets sends
an extra data point saying who entered
that row in the data set and so the
questions we're going to address today
who are the contributors to this data
set who is it that gave us data points
what are the department's weekday coffee
habits is it Monday it's a difficult day
and the after the weekend you come in
you have some coffee is it Friday it's
the last day of the week and then how
much coffee are people drinking in a per
capita base all right so let's begin if
you're using a knife Python notebook you
want to type this if you're using spider
or a wreck hole or anything like that
you don't need that second line what
that second line does is it just tells
pandas and matplotlib under under the
hood that if I asked you for a plots
just show me the plot immediately under
the cell all right so let's run now
everyone happy so far any questions all
right so let's import some data this is
what all of our cells where we have to
type things and look like right now so
I'm going to get rid of this how to
import data in pandas that's kind of the
number one question is and this is there
for data manipulation we need to get it
into the package so the first thing
we're going to do is we're going to pull
from a data data file called Coffey's
dot csv and the easy way to do that is
pay pangos go read a CSV all right done
no errors that went just great pandas is
able to import from directly from sequel
it's able to import hdf5 files it's able
to import from Jason and all sorts of
other formats very very flexible what
does the data look like well the easiest
way to check is just say hey python what
does the data look like and it looks
like that now that's a lot of data and I
don't particularly like the format of it
so I'm just going to skip ahead
immediately and say hey data dot head
show me the first few rows of this data
set all right so what we can observe
immediately is we have an index on the
Left that's just running from zero one
two three four all the way up to the
number of rows we have and then we have
three columns the first one is the
timestamp column and that contains this
kind of information here Coffey's and
contributor does anyone notice any
problems with this data set I'm sorry
missing data right missing data comes in
the form of these nuns that means not a
number probably at the CSV there was
nothing in that field anything else
okay so everything here is a float were
as we'd expect coffees to be integers
how about this guy turns out one I wrote
this app I didn't do any validation so
you could write whatever garbage you
want so that's not good so we
immediately have a few things we need to
clean and that's what this says so in
index in three columns and then you guys
have highlighted already the three
problems just that are immediately
apparent with this data set there are
going to be others because no data is
ever clean alright let's look at that
string in the third row we're going to
use these methods called lock or dot I
lock so I'm going to do data lock -
because I want the third row all right
there it is the third row has a
timestamp a coffee isn't a contributor
field does anyone know the difference
between dot lock and dialog
one is strings ones numbers okay so what
Locke does is it's a location-based
accessor and it looks for something
that's present in your index now here I
said lock of two and two is in my index
and it's my third row so that's perfect
I lock is an integer lookup and not just
it's like accessing a list in Python or
a numpy array you just pass it the index
of where you want to go down the data
frame so in this case I can do exactly
the same with I lock and get the same
data back because index two points to
Row two perfect everyone happy with that
so the number of coffees here is
definitely a string something we'll have
to fix we'll come back to that let's
take a look at that na N and in fact why
don't we look at at the first five
values in coffees now coffees is a
column of the data frame so if I say
data doc coffees what am i accessing
here I've got a series so this is just
the values in that column and I can
access I can index them using square
brackets like I would a normal list or
an array so if I say hey give me the
five first then we have the five first
elements in that series so the
difference between a series and the data
frame is that a data frame contains
multiple columns all of which can be
viewed as series and will be coming will
be juggling the two quite often
how's my speed is everyone keeping up
okay great
all right how long is the data set I've
put in a little bit of a cheat here but
I think anyone in in Python wouldn't
know what to use if I wanted the length
of any interval 671 data points
what else can we find out well we've
used dot head to look at the first few
rows we can use doc described and this
can return a number of things based on
what's in the data frame but if we do it
just as is what do we get
well we get it looks like another data
frame actually the index is a bunch of
strings but this is a data frame there
is a column for every column that we
have timestamp coffees and contributor
and then there are a few different
objects in there so there's a count how
many columns are there how many objects
are in the timestamp column 671 and
that's the length of our data frames
that's great
but in coffees they're only 658
different objects and that's because we
spotted some na and some no values
contributor it doesn't look like it's
missing anything so that's great how
many unique values well we only have
nine different people contributing to
this data set unique timestamps it's
great that they're all unique because in
theory they should all be following each
other and no two people should be using
the app at the same time and then the
top and the most frequent this is just
the the first value in the timestamp and
this is the sorry this is the most
common value in the timestamp and
because they're all unique they're all
as frequency to other so here's just
picked a random one and it said that the
frequency of that is one but two people
apparently entered that there were seven
5216 coffees because that's a frequency
of two
so we are missing some data and so we're
going to have to fix that we can either
drop those rows because they're not
contributing anything or we can try to
interpolate over the NA ends and we'll
do both today but we're so a data frame
contains several columns and each of
those columns can be viewed so columns
go down let me pull up all right this is
a data frame you can view the timestamp
column as a series you can view the
coffee's column as a series in fact why
don't we do this if I say hey data dot
coffees I'm accessing the coffee's
column and the type of this is a pandas
series object whereas the type of the
data is a data frame object there are
two ways to access a series from a data
frame I like the dot notation I find
it's nice and clean but you can also
access it using string
okay
all right by the way shout out as much
as you like I like the back and forth
okay so we spotted that we're missing
values and coffees so we're going to try
to figure out where coffees is known and
see if there are any patterns there so
my hands here is use the dot is null
method and then brilliant indexing what
does this mean well we have data and we
can look at is know right off the bat
all right do we spot any truths anywhere
there's a true so this is now asking for
is this value no at any of these points
in the data frame if I want it for the
coffees only what would I have to change
so again
thought coffees thought is no awesome
all right and that's now return to
series again now the great thing about
this is its return to series with the
same index that we have on our data
frame and it's obviously the same size
as we have to so what I can do is I can
use this as a boolean index and I can
say why don't you return to me the data
where data's Kofi's is know just by
doing that and so I have pulled out all
of the rows where coffees is null right
now it looks like they're spread pretty
much over time we start in October 2011
and then there's still some nulls in
2013
it looks like it's by a mix of
contributors and indeed we can confirm
everything is no in there
so how about that problem with the
strings in the coffee's column well I
can say what's the d-type what's the
data type of all of the columns in my
data frame and what do we see that
they're all objects the contributor
column makes sense that it's an object
because object is what and this uses
when it means strings but surely the
timestamp column needs to be a date/time
object and it would make sense that the
coffee's column at least be some sort of
numerical type right should be probably
an int it could be a float if we really
wanted so D types so type is applied to
an object so here if I apply it to data
I get that data is a data frame if I
apply it to data D types I should get
that's a series and that's because if I
look at what data to D type on its own
gives me back it's a series where the
indices are the names of my columns and
then the values are the type that that
column is so del D types is looking at
the column it's looking at all of the
elements in that column and it's pulling
from that to say these are objects or
these are floating point numbers d types
should work on series too I think
yep d type always an object d type comes
from numpy if you've ever used that
numpy arrays can contain floating points
they could be integers they could be all
sorts of different details
so here what we're saying is these are
all objects and that doesn't make sense
we want the data to be in the right
format so we can analyze it correctly so
let's inspect what's in that timestamp
column because those timestamps need to
be date/time objects num Python has a
great day time library pandas does a lot
of great stuff on top of that so we want
to use it so print the first element in
the series
let's see well so the series is
referring to you is the timestamp column
so if I say data dot timestamp that'll
print the first element and how about
the type of the first element well I can
print the type of data timestamp and I
want to access the first element here so
the first element looks like this and
it's a string object does anyone know
why it might be a string object instead
of a date/time
I imported it from a CSV if you're not
familiar with the CSV it's like a really
basic text file now Excel can open these
it's called comma separated value and
it's just a list of all of your all of
your data separated by commas and
because it's a plain text thing it's
pretty dumb and we don't know that these
things should be date times so they've
been readiness strings I actually
consider myself pretty fortunate that
pandas was intelligent enough to
interpret most of the rest as floats so
one more thing we need to add to our
cleaning list is we all the time stamps
to be daytime objects and not strings
all right so this is everything we found
so far that's wrong the timestamp column
contains strings but they should be date
types the coffee's column contains both
no values and we saw at least one string
so we need to clean all of that up so
that was our kind of first pass we're
going to do some cleaning and then after
that we'll answer some of those
questions a quick show of hands for how
many people are following along in the
notebook how are you finding it speed is
okay yeah all right don't hesitate to
shout out any questions all right let's
clean this up
the coffee's column should contain only
numerical data
pandas ever wonderful provides us with
this method called two numeric so if I
say hey take the coffee's take data
coffees which is a series and set it
equal to the numeric of data coffees is
it that simple is really going to work
well the answer here is no it's never
that simple but it's very close all
right if we look at this error really
quickly we see that it was unable to
parse a string testing that was our
string in the third or fourth column
right third and fourth row what it's not
saying is I was able to parse all of
those n/a ends if I'm missing a value
and you tell me to turn something into a
numerical column I'll just ignore those
because those are you know an n/a n is a
valid number surprisingly but what it
couldn't do is parse the string testing
now we're going to use something that's
a keyword argument to two numeric we're
going to say errors coerce and what that
says is anytime you find an error just
dump it and turn it into an n a n and
that's really helpful because we only
had one string I can tell you because I
know the data set you should have
checked but we only had one string and
it's not providing us any information we
don't know how many coffees there was on
that time so if I run this cell now
these are now numerical and I can check
that let me comment this line out and
then I'm gonna say data dot d types we
have now a numerical object the whole
column contains numerical objects we
don't contain strings anymore what we do
have are so many ends and that's fine we
were expecting those
so I've taken a copy of the coffee
series I've cast it as a numerical and
I've said anytime you hit something that
you can't cast to a numerical by
yourself just get rid of it and then set
that back into the coffees column in my
data frame and I'm able to do that
because this operation doesn't change
the index right so data doc coffees is a
series but it still has an index and
when you try to do the qualities and
pandas it compares the indices all right
we solved one of our problems and that
was easier than I thought so moving on
it contains so many ends there are
several ways to deal with these as we
said one of them you could just pretend
they don't exist just drop the rows you
could also fill in the rows maybe by
interpolating if you have a value above
and below maybe take you mean we can be
more clever than that later we'll look
at the times and the dates that we have
and we'll draw a straight line between
two dates and then wherever our value
lies along that line that's the value
we'll give it so that's just an
interpolation between dates not between
two points that are equally distant but
for now we're going to start easy and
we're going to use a convenient method
called drop any now if I drop in a as it
is it's going to return a data frame and
it still has rnase and that's because a
lot of what pandas does is it operates
on copies of objects and that's for
safety you often don't want to mutate
things in place but in this case it's
perfectly safe to do so so I'm gonna say
do it in place and if I run that now
check out our indices we've lost rows
two and three and we've lost the index
that belonged to them too but now we've
dropped any rows that contain and not a
number
there are two ways to do this this as I
said was in place you could also have
done data is data drop in a because this
is actually working this part is
actually dropping the anaise but then
it's just giving you back the object and
you're not holding on to it that's what
we did the first time now we're saying
just set it equal to data any questions
on that one so far
no because what this is doing here is
it's it's dropping those rows and that
gives us this result and then you're
saving this result on top so you you
keep the dropped index you know you keep
the index where you're no longer
perfectly sequential alright so the
coffee's we saw that I was a
floating-point column I will confirm
that again so let me cancel this and let
me say doc D types and it's a float64 I
want us to be integers really so what
I'm gonna do is use as type int it's
like speaking English it's so easy
alright those coffees are integers now
and again I can look at the D types and
they're now 64-bit integers instead of
floats
how about the timestamps well if you've
ever messed with date time objects
you'll know they're generally a bit of a
pain you have to take the string and
break it up into the year in the month
in the day and the minutes you have to
drop the microseconds because who cares
and then you've got to create a
date/time object from that and that's
that's annoying but once again in pandas
makes it pretty easy we're going to say
to date time
all right and now we have date/time 64
objects in the timestamp column
to end generally you want to cast it to
numeric first as we did numeric will
default to floats if it finds a mixed
type and we had floats first so it will
go to floats and then we do as type int
and the reason is to numeric handles the
case of error handling so if I used dot
as type int the first pass they would
have failed on that string there is no
two int method there is a two numeric
and then you turn that into an end okay
so again you go d-type 6000k you're
probably running on a slightly different
version of pandas the defaults to 32-bit
integers alright everyone happy with
that yes
hi
it absolutely has that data and you do
have that day let me repeat the question
the index that was non-sequential after
we dropped some rose in strange but you
have access to this it's an actual piece
of data contained in the data frame and
what you see here is we go 0 1 4 5
because we dropped 2 & 3 you can
consider the index a primary key if you
will there's no guarantee that your
index has to be sequential and
well-formed and unique but if you don't
pass an index into a data frame pandas
will create one for you starting at 0
and going to the length of your data
frame minus 1 and these these objects
truly are attached to the rows and we'll
find that that's really useful later all
right
everyone happy with this one all right
so where do we stand we did some
cleaning let's use describe again if I
use describe it's only described in the
coffee's column to me now and that's
because I have a coffee's column which
is a an integer I have an object column
for the contributor and I have a
date/time column for the timestamp and
when pandas is faced with different D
types in its data frames and you asked
for describe it will default to first
the numeric values but what I can do is
I can say I can include this include
argument to see all of the information
and that just looks like this hey tell
me everything so we have our count again
we saw count unique top and frequent all
right that was the first time we hit
described and it's saying that the time
stands there are 657 of them
there was 657 coffees in 657
contributors that's because we've
dropped all na s that's great and then
it's given me a bunch of Nan's for you
know what's the most frequent value well
it what does it mean to have a most
frequent value for you know is something
that's a continuous number generally it
doesn't mean much so it's telling me I
I can't tell you that but it does tell
me what's the mean number of coffees
what's the standard deviation what's the
minimum and maximum what are the
quartiles so that's pretty handy so we
can immediately see we started at 397
coffees and went up to 24,000 in a bit
what about the first few rows because
we've done a lot of changing now so how
do I get the first few rows say gun
I'm going to use look alright so why do
I need to use lock for I lock because
this is a data frame and if I try to
access it without the square brackets
it's going to run through my index
London my bad all right so here are the
first five rows this is a well-behaved
integer these things contain no more
they never contain anything bad we have
no na s here and these are actually
date/time objects which again we can
confirm using D types great so we know
how we're in a place where our data
frame is looking good things are as they
should be and the data is ready to do
some analysis on is everyone following
ok all right so Sagan
did we do something with a string it's
an object so so an object is pandas
notation for Strings strings and other
objects all right so at a glance let's
look at this time series why don't we
begin by plotting it so if I say so the
hint here is plot on the coffee series
so that's the data frame that's the
coffee series what's plotted is everyone
managing to get a graph all right no
right hands up if you don't have a graph
do you know what the issue is
so again
[Music]
all right I'll give you just a minute
while we're waiting does anyone notice
anything strange about this graph it's a
time series it should be a time series
why is it plotting zero to however long
our data frame is it's plotting it's the
index that's right also something I want
to draw your attention to is this little
spike here and we'll get we'll get rid
of that in a bit but okay so it's
plotting against the index which is a
series of integers so it's doing
something strange it's not taking into
account the distance between date times
let's use the data frames plot method
instead of the series plot method and we
can pass in the index so my hen says
plot on the data frame which looks like
that setting X to the timestamp and then
a dot dash style so I look something
like this all right what have I done
here I've said hey plot the whole data
frame use the data use the timestamp
column as your as your X plot anything
numerical on the Y and here we only have
one numerical thing that's the coffees
and then style it with dash which is
basically a straight line and also dots
where we have values and the reason I
did that is you can see that here
there's an entire several months where
no one's entered any data and then here
there are a few plateaus as well I can
explain these this looks like Christmas
break this looks like maybe Easter break
or something like that this is where I
left the University of Warrick and this
is when I came back and visited that's
not terribly useful the resolution here
is awful so one of the things we're
going to do is get rid of it yeah
do I need a different date table
so we don't have that problem here
because we don't have any dates with
nothing in them if you were plotting a
series that contains some na s there
would be missing chunks in the graph no
okay so let's inspect the last few
points this time series just to confirm
it's what we thought it was so we had
dot head earlier but we can use doc tail
and I'm going to pass in N equals 10
because I want 10 rows this time and so
here are the last 10 rows of this data
set and what do we see
March 4th March 4th 5th 8th and then 1
the 12th someone else contributed and
then someone else contributed
sporadically for about a month and then
there was nothing for 5 months and then
I came back and visited so that's what
we thought it was but just for
simplicity I'm gonna I'm gonna get rid
of that tail because it's not
particularly useful doesn't tell us that
much you may disagree with my choice on
that but because this is a really quick
dirty analysis we're just gonna skip it
for now so I'm gonna get rid of
everything after the 1st of March and
we're going to use conditional indexing
here so what does conditional indexing
look like I'm going to blank these out
first and I'm gonna say data timestamp
is less than 2030 no 301 what's this
gonna give me a series of series of true
or false a series of bullying's
excellent that's what that looks like
all over the start of the time series is
before March of 2013 well that makes
sense but we've already seen boolean
indexing we've seen how we can use a
series of trues and falses to index
across the data right and that looks
like that that's another data frame and
if I look at the tail of that it ends on
the 27th of February that's great so
we've we've chopped off everything after
the 1st of March just want to bring you
to the the simplicity of this we passed
in this string as the date here and
pandas converted that to a date time for
us and filtered anything that was not
less than that
so again these are time stamps with no
time zones so I'm going to do I'm going
to cut off that tail so I'm just going
to say I'm going to take this expression
I head down here and I'm just going to
put it after the equals and say data is
the same thing as data but it's only
wherever the timestamp is less than
March 2013 and then if I look at the
tail of that that's healthy that's good
it's one final look why don't we plot
the data against the time stamp do you
remember how to do that plot the X is
the time stamp I'm just going to leave
it as is we don't need the start
actually let's put in the style let's do
top - again all right so we're good
and by the way you can do things like
you can pass in arguments for how big
you want the plot to be you can pass in
a title you can pass in labels all this
users map plot live under the hood to
generate these graphs so we we see our
Christmas break again we see down I took
two months off that's not good
and then we see another kind of
Christmas break around here everyone
happy with the way we have the data set
all right let's start answering that
first question who contributed to our
data set so I'm going to look at the
contributors column that's a series
makes sense and series have a method
called value counts which just returns a
series it's indexed by the unique values
within that series so in that case
that's all of our names and then it
counts the number of times that unique
value occurs so that was a really quick
quick way of counting over all of our
individual contributors
but if you're like me you like charts
and this is kind of hard to read so why
don't we plotted so I'm going to do the
same I'm going to take data contributor
value counts and I'm going to plot but
I'm going to pass kind equals bar
I'd like to thank Arturo for
contributing I'm sorry
didn't need to because when you plot a
series of plots against its index and
the index of this series is our unique
names yep so I didn't need to pass in an
x value here
everyone got to this point is anyone
struggling confused behind few people
confused let me take two what's up guys
okay all right I can go back over that
I'm just gonna go over the chopping the
tail off really quickly all right so
here's the here's the statement I'm
going to start in the middle of those
brackets and I'm gonna say the timestamp
of the data is less than March 2013 and
for every row you're gonna say yes it is
yes it is yes it is no it's not and
there's some point where you're going to
transition from yes to no I'm going to
use that series of yes and nose to index
my data frame and so I'm going to say
only return rows where this index is
true and so it's only returning rows
where the timestamp is less than March
2013 and then I'm setting that into my
data
all righty
I was gonna keep it I wanted to see who
is contributing not because I like
seeing my name up there promise
no it's just it's just an interesting
question is how did this dataset get
built up you want to see the same per
month okay
so we're gonna do some operations later
called resampling and we'll get things
into per day and per week per month is
the same we're not quite set up for it
yet what we need to do is change our
index to be a timestamp index and we'll
do that in a bit
do we have a group this is a group by a
contributor yeah okay
all right so here's a question we looked
at who put these data points into the
data set how about on what days were
people active inputting data into the
data set
does anyone expect anything interesting
here just looking you know Mondays what
do we think well it's a data little data
I think a lot of data how about Sunday
probably not though it is a maths
Department people were there on Sunday
so the hint here says create a series of
the weekdays for each entry so I'm gonna
look at data timestamp because this is a
timestamp column it has access to this
dot DT attribute D T stands for
date/time and this opens up a whole
world of new objects to us one of which
is dot weekday I'm going to blank those
out for now and I'm going to say hey I
just created this what does it look like
okay does anyone know what's going on
here
cereal is Monday but very close
it's zero to six it's because when
asking for the weekday not the day of
the month so yeah yeah this is still the
index of my entire data frame we've
still lost two and three and over here
zero is Monday Tuesday Wednesday
Wednesday Thursday Thursday Thursday
Thursday Thursday etc so what I'm going
to do I know it's not particularly
useful to have zero to six instead of
Monday to Sunday we'll change that in a
minute
but first I want to save this data to my
data frame because it's super handy to
be able to refer and just say hey on any
given row what day was it well I'm going
to assign it to my data frame so I'm
going to use data dollar sign and I want
to say hey the weekdays column is this
weekdays object that I just created and
so then I'm going to look at the head
and I'm gonna see I haven't brand new
column called weekdays which contains
the day of the week does that make sense
why am i using dollar sign here later
we're going to use a more direct way of
adding a column pandas is incredibly
intelligent under the hood and so what
it does is it optimizes a great deal of
operations so when you use data from
your own from your own data frame and
you try to assign it in a new form to
the same data frame it may or may not
give you a warning saying hey you're
you're using a copy here instead of a
view or you're using a view instead of a
copy and what that means is if your data
frame changes at a later date you may be
changing data that you didn't know you'd
be changing so often when you get that
warning it's worth heeding here I got
the warning in the simple way to assign
it so I'm just gonna say dot assign
which takes a copy of that instead of a
view and just slams a new column into
place everyone following
all right but as we said in cero to six
not very helpful I created here a
standard Python list Monday Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday all the way to Sunday
I created a dictionary that map's 0 to 6
which I got from range 7 here to this
string so if I look at what that looks
like
it's a simple Python dictionary going
from zero to six in the keys Monday to
Sunday in the in the values and I'm
going to use a Matthews a function
called apply and I'm going to apply a
custom function that I'm going to write
to this column so that I can turn my
zeros to sixes to Monday to Sunday so
how many people are familiar with lambda
functions all right so I'm going to use
something that's not a lambda so I'm
gonna write a function I want to say hey
day of week and it's gonna take some
index I'll call it idx and I'm gonna say
return weekday names of that index sorry
we take dict of that it looks actually
would be exactly the same to use just
the list but I'm going to do this and
I'm just gonna show you that works so
let's print weekday dick let's play
let's print day of week of zero and I
get Monday
and then of - I'm gonna get Wednesday
great so that works so now I'm going to
use the supply method I'm going to say
hey data weekdays you're going to become
data weekdays where I'm going to apply a
method day of week so this is a function
I wrote it's going to look at the value
in the weekdays series and whatever that
value is if it's a zero if it's a six is
going to pass that as an argument to day
of week and it's going to save the
result on top of it so now if I look at
data ahead my weekday is a far more
human illegible any questions
okay let's group by the weekdays alright
so the original question on this part of
the tutorial was on which days are
people contributing so now we have
Monday to Sunday and I want to group
them up I want to say take all of the
Monday's together and count them take
all of the Tuesdays together and count
them now that sounds incredibly like
values count value counts which we used
earlier right so we could use that but
we're going to use this group by which
is an extremely powerful method that
just brings anything together as you
tell it so you're gonna say data dot
weekdays sorry why don't I want here I'm
going to take the data I'm going to
group it by the weekdays column and let
me show you what that looks like
currently that is a data frame group by
object it's not giving me any
information and that's because what I've
said is take all of the values in the
weekdays column and just group them up
if they're the same so now I have seven
groups I have the Monday group the
Tuesday group the Wednesday group but I
haven't said what to do with those
groups well the easiest thing to do is
to count the groups and now suddenly I
have a data frame where so I have three
columns in my data frame so why am i
counting each column given that they all
have the same thing why don't I take
I'll keep it for now
once right I must write let's try taking
weekdays don't group a that doesn't work
let's leave it as is
alright so now what I have is a data
frame where the indices are weekday
indices that's the title there
the Friday column contains 114 rows in
all three columns Monday is 145 Sunday
is 13 I don't like the ordering though
Monday Friday Monday Saturday Sunday
Thursday or it's not great so why don't
we reorder that why don't we say it's
weekday counts and you remember that
list we had above the list of weekday
names which is ordered well I'm just
going to use that
that's because
I'm sorry let me cheat
I'm doing this on the fly my bad by
cleaning the data where do we stand done
that
if you can see that this is what that
lambda would have looked like so a
lambda is just an anonymous function
it's a function that I'm saying here's a
function don't bother giving it a name
just apply it here's what that function
does okay let me go back here what did I
do wrong here well this thing is a data
frame right and if we want to access the
data frame by its index then we're gonna
need to use don't look it was looking
for Monday in the data frame and it was
saying where do you want me to find
Monday I'm trying to access this by rows
by the number of rows but you have to
say no look in the index and that's what
that does
can you Sagan previous step yep
so previous step we created this
function that just returns a string and
when you give it an index for the the
weekday and then we said take the
weekdays and apply that function to it
so turn those things into that function
[Music]
how many people are still with me at
this point yes all right
is everyone happy with this step - okay
all right let's visualize these weekday
accounts so we're going to do exactly
the same as we did before we're going to
take the data we had before which is
this week they counts data frame and so
I'm gonna take the weekday counts which
is my data frame and I'm gonna plot it
and it says to plot a bar chart so again
I'm going to pass kind equals bar all
right why do we have rainbow bar
suddenly we have three columns they all
contain exactly the same thing it's kind
of useless why don't I take weekday
counts and only keep one of the columns
doesn't matter which one I keep I want
to keep coffees because I like coffee
all right so now we have 1 bar because
we're only plotting one of the columns
in that data frame and what you can see
is that Monday was definitely the day
where people into the most data
Wednesday spiked surprisingly and then
Saturday and Sunday people weren't
really there very much but that's not
negligible so it's pretty great
questions
on to the second question it's gonna get
a little bit more difficult we're going
to figure out if there are any trends on
when people drink coffee during the week
now the trend we just saw was when do
people input data that is we were
counting the rows but now we want to
count the difference in coffees between
each row I want to know on which they
are people consuming the most coffee so
here's where it gets interesting I'm
going to take this data index which I
showed you earlier was it's just an
integer index and I'm going to replace
it by the timestamp column on that row
so I'm going to say data index is data
timestamp so what have I done I've
replaced my index with pandas just
created for me a date/time index which
contains all of my date times let's see
what the data set looks like now well
instead of that 0 1 4 5 6
we now have dates and remember these
aren't strings any marks we cast them to
date times we also have the date/time
column which contains exactly the same
information we have the number of
coffees the contributor and the weekday
that that day was yes we are working on
the original data frame which we've
cleaned at this point I mean we still
have that object that was the weekday
counts it's still there but you know
we've answered that question just about
so we're now answering a more difficult
question which is I know you give me
more data on Monday but on which day are
you going through my coffee beads
oh the index is gone if you try to index
and say give me the row at index 4
doesn't exist if you say give me the row
at exactly this index it'll give me back
that row yeah we now have a duplicate
timestamp that's it's it's not needed
yeah
so that's why this next line here says
hey why don't we drop it let's drop the
timestamp because we don't need it it's
already in the index I'm gonna use drop
dot drop takes in a list of objects to
drop and usually it's going to look for
these in the indices it's gonna say oh
you wanted to drop the fourth of
September but here I'm saying don't drop
a row drop a column I'm passing in the
column name and I'm saying XS equals 1
means to look at this axis look at this
axis look for the columns to drop and
then if you remember this in place
equals true back when we drop an aid we
use that to say so I don't have to say
data equals this just drop the
colonisers yes
so that's a bad place to be if there
were duplicate values in the index it'll
depend what kind of manipulation you're
doing if the type of things we're going
to be doing today it shouldn't matter if
there are duplicates but as we saw
earlier each value was unique so that's
that's great
because the data frame cannot exist
without an index so I can't drop the
index so what I did is I copied the
timestamp to the index and then I'm
going to drop the column yep
[Music]
if I had a more complicated data frame
you don't have to have the date and time
if you have a you could have a date time
index where the date of the times are
all midnight we will do that later you
can have timestamp indexes with time
zones
the pandas kind of date manipulation is
pretty powerful yeah access equals one
says when you're looking for this value
timestamp to go drop usually by default
it would look at ax is zero which looks
at the rose and so it if you want to say
drop zero it would drop the row with the
index zero in this case I don't want to
drop any rows I want to drop an entire
column so I want to drop something
that's going down instead of something
that's going across so that's what
access equals one does so if I run this
now I no longer have that timestamp
column I have timestamp in my index and
then I have three columns coffees
contributor and weekdays
all right what I want to do now is it's
a bit complicated I want to insert rows
every day at midnight and the reason is
I have a bunch of rows sampled at really
arbitrary times like a 22 in the morning
and 11 48 in the morning but I want to
get one value per day and the best way I
can think of doing that
is adding in one day every single day at
midnight and then finding the value of
the number of coffees at that point and
then dropping my rows that are not at
midnight does that operation make sense
I will see it as we go
I could but then I would be losing my
time information so here's an example if
well so I wish I had a board if you have
let's say you have ten coffees today one
in the morning and tomorrow
that one in the morning you have twenty
coffees what's the value going to be at
midnight this is going to be fifteen or
is it going to be nineteen well
midnight is closer to 1:00 in the
morning the next day so you want the
number to be closer to that so we're
going to do a linear interpolation
between the x not we're not just going
to drop the x because they are useful to
us so here's how we do that what you saw
above was that I had a
[Music]
yep so there are some days where I don't
have anything and that'll be problematic
there are some days where I have five
six seven entries and we'll have to do
something to merge those together but
more importantly if I drop my times then
if there's a man if there's a midnight
somewhere then I want to know the the
two numbers to either side of me which
ones closer to me how do I draw a
straight line between those numbers and
how do I figure out what value of
coffees I should be at midnight so this
is a daytime index and you know the
first ones at 822 then 11:48 so we're
going to create another index and this
index is going to live outside of a data
frame first of all we're going to create
a date range and there's no date range
and it's going to start at data dot
index 0 which is the first value of the
index it's going to end at data dot
index minus 1 which is the last index
it's going to have a frequency of days
and then it's going to normalize equals
true what this means is make these data
points at midnight all right and so
these things don't no longer have a time
now they are just days but they are one
a day every day from the start of my
series to the end of my series let me
show you what normalize equals false
would do
everything's at 8:22 now we could do
that that's fine but it doesn't make
much sense so I want to keep it clean
have just days let me show you what
happens if we have a frequency of W what
do we get every week yep days is what we
want okay it's a date time index of date
times 64 D type of frequency days and
there are 514 days everyone following
yes
because doclock returns something that's
inside a row and the index is separate
from the row so if I did I mean kill
nurse if I say data index zero I get
back that very first time stamp if I did
don't look 0 well 0 isn't in my index if
I did that I log 0 I get the first row
but there's no timestamp information in
that row it's hidden away in the name of
this series which is less useful so I'm
using the index directly because I can
access that so that looks like this yes
why
just because I want to keep things clean
and have one day at midnight today I
don't want I don't want to present
anyone my report and say hey here's a
list of every coffee drunk on every day
by the way the day starts at a 22 a.m.
that doesn't make much sense alright so
we have this index of days and in our
data frame separately we have an index
that's kind of randomly spaced uniform
it's not a uniformly spaced data frame
where every data point every row has the
exact same interval between it that's
what our new index is for so what we're
going to do is we're going to create a
new index that takes the union of both
of those all right so our previous index
was called Midnight's so I'm gonna say
hey take the index called Midnight's and
take the Union with our index that is
come up with a new index that has the
values of both of these indices together
in one index and make sure it's sorted
in order and that's what that looks like
so we start on October 3rd at midnight
and then we have October 3rd at 822 in
the morning then we have October 4th
October 4th at 11:48 in the morning
October 5th at midnight you see how this
is going
cool everyone's still following along
great yes
can you speak up please frequency equals
none is what it says for the granularity
there and that's because these things
are not uniformly spaced yeah before
Midnight's it doesn't have it doesn't
have a time it's only a date if you mash
together a date in a date time it's
gonna give the dates midnight yeah so
that's why everything here do you false
to midnight I don't have any duplicates
on this one not unless somebody put in
an entry exactly at midnight we worked
hard but I don't think we worked that
hard so yes
so if we turn it into midnight why are
we still seeing these random times
that's because this is Midnight's
unioned with the current index this is
midnight plus all of the stuff we
currently have now what I want to do is
I want to take my data frame which is
indexed at random times I want to slide
in some indices that are very regular
and then I'm gonna have a data frame
full of data and nuns because I don't
know what happens at midnight but I know
what happened
you know at 8:22 in the morning just
before that and so what we're gonna be
able to do from that is fill in all the
blanks so I'll show you that in a minute
so what we can do is reinvent our data
frame so our data frame is still called
data so I'm gonna take data and I'm
going to re index it on our new index
and let me show you what that looks like
by showing the first 10 rows of that our
first time is October 3rd at midnight we
don't know how many coffees we don't
know who the contributor was we don't
know what day that is that's because
I've just invented a row and I haven't
given it any data the next is a row that
we actually had then it's another
midnight we don't know what the
information is and then a 0 we had so
you're starting to see what we can do
here we can say well I want to fill in
this coffee value here and it's
somewhere between 8:00 in the morning on
the third and 11:48 on the 4th find me a
value that fits in that gap
everyone happy with that so pandas
didn't invent any data for us it just
filled everything in with I don't know
how many people are familiar yep
is NaN the default
[Music]
yes so what I could do here is I'll
figure this on the fly you could feel
Phil Knowles with one two three all
right
great and that's useful because
sometimes nulls actually mean something
informative like my machine was broken
in this case it just means I'm creating
dates and I don't have a reading for
that date so we're gonna fill those in
how many people are familiar with
interpolation
okay so interpolation is saying I have
we need a board I have a number of
points and then there's this little gap
where I don't know what the value is if
I look at the points nearby the simplest
kind of interpolation is called linear
interpolation I look at the point to the
left of me the point to the right of me
and I take an average now I take an
average make sense if I'm equally spaced
between all of my points but as we can
see we're not equally spaced so we're
going to do interpolation across time
which is to say plot this against the
time axis and then wherever the line is
take that value instead which is going
to be between the value before and the
value after but it might be closer to
the value after if the time I'm sampling
out is closer to the value after
alrighty we're gonna fill these nine
lists using interpolation so my hint
says interpolate the up sample data
using the time method could it be as
simple as take the up sample data or
interpolate method equals time why yes
it is this value existed this value
existed here's a midnight that's a weird
number of coffees but that is the number
of coffees interpolated between these
times
we can turn it into an INT I'm not going
to bother just because I'm just going to
plot this but so the cool thing here is
if you take the average of these two
numbers it's lower than this number this
number is closer to this number because
midnight is closer to this time than it
is to this time so we've maintained our
temporal information as we interpolate
it over yes and no you can specify
column to interpolate over but there are
some some of the more complex methods
like time I call it complex it's not
really that hard but some of the methods
that aren't just straight interpolate
they will give you a warning and say you
can't do this so let's say what happens
if I take up sample data that
interpolate method equals nearest for
example that gives us here it's using
the time index again so if I as you say
I just want to interpolate the coffee's
with the time method I think well it
works here okay so I use a previous
method earlier maybe one of the
quadratic methods and it it wants to use
the index for more complicated things
what we'll see later is that it's is
just nice to have in index that
represents what you're actually indexing
on
yep because we cast it to date time and
if you remember if we if we look at the
index then the objects are date time
objects and it's a date time index so it
it knows how to do time interpolation
alrighty that's where we stand now we
filled in all of those nouns yes
I
okay so the method equals time means
you're going to be doing a linear
interpolation where the x-axis instead
of being an arbitrary index of points is
a time value
[Music]
you could use nearest I think or you can
use linear as a method I think the
default let me see what does a default
look like the default here is using time
as well because it's a nice and clever
let's try a quick hack let's say my data
frame is is my up sample data and I'm
only going to keep the coffee's column
and I'm gonna say that the index is
going to be that and what does that look
like alright so now we have hold on I
want to do this before that so I want to
use data here alright now we have the
number of coffees
and let me set okay that's fine
that didn't work
can we think you on the fly here it
smell very nice okay how's that worked
this is still not gonna work of it oh no
it is working I just keep resetting it
every time because I'm clever no I give
up we'll look at it later
just in the interest of time I'm gonna
keep going
so come on
yes okay all right we have a nun all
right let's do some interpolate if I
just interpolate that looks like exactly
the mean of these two values okay what
interpreted did by base here is it said
I don't have any information on which I
can do this I'm just going to pretend my
micro distant between point zero and
point two that is basic temporal the
basic linear interpolation what we did
with the dot time method is we said use
your index it's a time index time tells
you how far points are from each other
because these rows are not equi distant
from each other use that to do your
linear interpretation have answered your
question
right yes that will work you you may
come across a problem where you have to
set that float column as your index
depending on the type of method you're
using to interpolate because over here
let's see what we have all right so
here's that I don't have a note on it
and does interpolate once you look at
the data frame one so here all of the
methods you could use and here's the one
we use time interpolation works on daily
and high-resolution data so that means
anything with a time to interpolate the
given length of the interval if you use
linear you would have ignored the index
and treated the values as equally spaced
so had I just read the docs
I could probably have done that from the
start here was that method we used let's
use linear
still using tile isn't still using time
okay yep tell you what I've already
interpolated my Nance I'm not going to
bother putting them back in let's come
back to it I just want to make sure we
we finish on time okay is everyone happy
with filling in the Nan's as we've done
so far yes
we're now ready to resample it at a
daily frequency now if you if you
remember what we had we had we had so
this would be daily if I had these rows
here and then this row but we have all
of these extra things so we're we're
over daily right now and we don't want
that so I'm going to create a data frame
called daily data and it's going to use
the up sampled and I'm going to re
sample from it and I'm gonna resample
daily and I'm gonna use ass freak
alright let me show you without ass
freak first
this is a date time index resampler and
this looks curiously like our are
grouped by object from earlier that is
it's an object that kind of has mashed
some things together but it's not giving
us any information and that's because
this is very akin to a group by this is
saying look at the time stamps being
everything in two days I just group them
in today if these two rows fall into the
same day put them together in the same
group but I haven't told you what to do
with the group so I could do several
things I could take the mean of all the
bins in the group or I could use say the
count of everything in the group which
we've already done but what I'm going to
do is I'm going to say you ask freak
which is basically saying resample daily
and only take the tone only take the
Midnight's on that day so it's very
helpful because we've put in the mid
nights and we've inferred the values at
those Midnight's so we're very happy
with this now and as you can see we have
lost our time information in our index
because we don't need it anymore
everything is equally spaced one day
apart alright well we now have a
contributors and a weekdays column which
we don't need and the reason we don't
need them is they're full of nines they
don't contain any information so here
I'm only going to drop the contributor
column so I'm going to say daily data is
daily data dot drop
contributor access is won cuz we're
dropping a column not a row if I look at
daily data now we've dropped that column
excellent and then I'm going to generate
a column for the weekday names because
remember we had these weekdays and we
figured out the weekdays were from zero
to six and then we applied a custom
function well I cheated you I lied
there is a weekday name attribute which
gives us that information automatically
so what have we done here we've said
take the weekdays column and set it as
the index top value name indexed a
weekday name sorry so you take 3 at the
index which is a list of dates and then
you say what's the day of the week for
each of those and so we have that
information back so now what we have is
our original data set but instead of
being sparsely sampled at weird times
it's now uniformly homogeneously sampled
at midnight on every day yes
if you have some values for midnight
when we took a union
I believe it acts like a set which is to
say that it only keeps unique values so
you would have had the number of coffees
on that date at midnight but you would
only have had one midnight
so resample basically says it's like a
group buy and it's it's a bit more
complicated than a group buy because on
a group buy we said look at the unique
values in this column you know Monday
Tuesday Wednesday and any row that has
Monday group them into the Mondays
anywhere that has a Tuesday group them
into the Tuesdays and then do something
with those groups like count the number
of things in those groups how many
things came out on a Monday that was
group buy on it on the day of the week
resample does very similar but it
creates the groups for you and here it's
creating groups that are spread apart by
one day exactly so group anything that
was that landed on the fourth if you had
three things on on the fourth three
people submitted coffee values put them
into the group of the fourth and then
you could do mean which we did and that
would just say for the row that should
be the result of that on the fourth take
the mean of everything else we didn't
want the mean because if we had you know
an 8 o'clock and 9 o'clock and an 11:00
p.m. coffee we don't want to take the
mean of that and say that's what
happened at midnight we have the values
at midnight and we want to keep only the
values at midnight and that's what as
Freak does it basically says okay so on
the third we're on the fourth you had
three values one of them was a midnight
one of them was at 11:00 in the morning
only keep the one at midnight it's like
saying give me give me this resembled as
a daily frequency as frequency
you don't have to speak up man what is
the unit number of coffees made up until
that date and the reason it's
floating-point now is because well some
coffee one coffee was made at 11:00 one
coffee was made the next day and this is
pretending that that's happens at a
uniform rate yes
resample has an on keyword so you can
resample on a column
[Music]
it's gonna say I don't know how to
interpret strings as dates or it might
be clever and try to cast it for you
okay any other questions on that all
right
so let's plot this data let's see what's
more once more what it looks like and I
think I called the daily data all right
all right that looks like what we had
before except now we know that the data
for the coffee's is no longer an integer
and we know that the times are no longer
sampled sparsely we know we know that
they're not at random times and I can
show you that by again putting a plot
sign on it I remember these plateaus for
their Christmas break and whatever we
don't have a gap anymore we still have
something for New Year's Eve we have a
number of coffees it might not be the
exact number of coffees but we have a
value we've done a we've done a
reasonable estimate okay
how many coffees were made on any given
day well what we have is a series of how
many coffees were made up until that day
how many coffees were made today well
it's however many we have today -
however they were yesterday and that's
just the diff that's just oh I'm getting
ahead of myself
all right that's later let's group by
weekday first of all so so coffees by
day is going to be do I want to do those
okay
it's going to be my daily data group by
there's a cold weekday yep it's called
weekdays and then I want to take the
mean of it all right
that's not particularly helpful
I missed a step
so again have you guys got this
differencing so okay let's put it in
alright let's do this
okay so what I want to do is I want to
use this oh here we go
okay here's what we should have so we're
gonna use Def on the coffee column and
then we're going to follow up with a
shift and I'll show you why so first I'm
going to say coffees made is my daily
data dot coffees so the number of
coffees we have diff and what diff does
is it just looks at the difference
between any two rows and if I look at
coffees made that looks like this so
what it's done is it says let's look at
the difference between this day in this
day and put that into this cell then
let's look at the difference between
this day and this day and let's put it
into this cell now I have two nines here
the first none I already had because I
interpolated from a midnight that I
didn't have data for prior to but this
one I shouldn't have and I have this
because the difference between these
first two rows I wanted to land on here
I want to say the three o'clock at
midnight I started the third on midnight
and the fourth on midnight the
differences in coffees should be
attributed to the day of the third not
the day of the fourth so we're going to
use a shift and we're just going to
shift everything by minus one shift all
of that up one great so that's coffees
made and what that says is on the fourth
3234 coffees were made on the fifth 55
coffins were made that should these are
Saturday and Sunday
let's have that as a column column is
coffees made today and it's just going
to take that coffees made series we just
created and then I'm going to look at my
data frame again and now I have a new
column with all of that information in
there and I was right these were Monday
Tuesday these are Saturday so
Saturday and Sunday hello Monday 10
times as many coffees is Sunday cool so
far everything seems to be in order
everyone happy with what we just did all
right now we can group this so we're
going to group by weekdays and what does
that look like that's another group by
objects what we've said is anything
that's got a Monday in the weekdays
column group it into the same bin and
now why don't you take the mean consider
that every Monday is equal how many
coffees were made on the average Monday
34 were made on the average Friday 37.8
were made on the average Monday the
average Sunday has a mere 15 coffees
made it's starting to get a bit out of a
bit of insight out of this but we're
going to sort that out because we didn't
like that so coffees by day is going to
be week all right so remember we had
that list Monday to Sunday yeah two
slides
[Music]
here I didn't do I did not use a sign so
what happened was this calculation on
the top row this is this returns a copy
simple operations will return a view and
what that says is it's like pointers if
you're familiar with that in C or C++
you have your data actually points to
somewhere else and then it calculates
things on the fly for simple operations
for complicated ones here I'm doing a
diff and then a shift and the shift is
going to break things the shift is going
to say I'm just gonna wrap this round 1
I'm gonna create a new object for that
and therefore I was able to safely
assign this column here this is most
often I would say in my experience
anyway I've been able to use this most
of the time occasionally I get this
weird warning and I have to dot assign
it to to do that safely in the notes on
these slides there are a couple of Stack
Overflow posts and you'll see the the
people explaining why you want to do
this when you should heed the warning
sometimes the warning is ignored because
it raises false positives yeah all
righty we've grouped them up we know how
many cup coffees are made on the average
day but again it's going Friday Monday
Saturday so we're going to sort that out
and then we're going to plot coffees by
day dog plots and we're gonna plot
another bar
what did I do
comfies by day week day names is a list
that's fine
coffees by day is a data frame so I
can't access it that way so I'm going to
access using the index that's much
better and then I can plot the bar chart
and did I break everything oh I want to
plot only the coffee's made today I
don't want to plot the total coffees
there we go all right so we're back to
what we had before Monday on the average
Monday 37 coffees are made Tuesday a
little bit more Wednesday big spike hard
day Wednesdays were seminar days someone
would come and give a talk at lunchtime
and everyone would sit around a coffee
first and discuss things so that makes
sense
I'm glad Thursday was clearly the hard
day and then Friday people slacked
all righty last couple of questions how
many coffees did people drink and this
is we're gonna see a little bit more of
the power of pandas here often you don't
have a nice clean data set in tablet
form you'll often have five six seven
different places to source your data
from the indices won't match and you
still have to join these together so
we're going to do a join here first
we're going to load in this data set
called people which just contains a
daily index and the number of people in
the department at the time so if you
remember how to do that we're gonna read
this is everything pandas can read from
by the way but we're just going to read
from CSV again and it's some data
Department members and that looks like
this it's once a month at the end of
August there were 12 people at the end
of September there were 14 people ok
really nice simple data set how do we
join something that's monthly to our
data set that's daily well first we're
going to do an outer join
does anybody want to know what
what a joint is okay those bad question
so what a joint is going to do is is
going to look at two data sets it's
going to compare one of the columns that
you're telling it to look at generally
that'll be the index but you can tell it
to look elsewhere
and you're gonna say wherever these
indices match create you know extend
that row the default in pandas is an
inner join which is to say if my first
data set has an index which doesn't
appear in my second data set drop that
row an outer join does the opposite it
says if if this one has an index and
this one doesn't keep that row and just
fill it with man so we're going to do
daily data is daily data drawing and I'm
going to join people and I'm going to do
an out for join on that what does that
look like let me just see what that
looks like
alright so what we have is on the third
we have this nine we had before on the
fourth we have everything that looks
fine and then we have a bunch of mans
for dates and members well so the dates
here is going to be Nan's all the way
down until we hit the the end of the
month because that's when we had our
data but so one thing we can do is
interpolate over using the nernst and
I'm using nearest here because
No okay I'm using nearest because the
points now equally spaced so if I look
at that that breaks so if mr. parelle
paren is there it's just not showing
over here so I'm using this new notebook
addition so this is a Jupiter notebook
but I'm using it in slide mode and I'm
running it live at the same time and
occasionally things are difficult let me
take this how does it differ it doesn't
differ
oh yes you're right when we loaded this
in I forgot to read half of my
instruction parse the dates all right
well let's say the index column is the
column called date and parse dates
equals true so let me space that out a
little bit that's a cheap we're cheating
all the way through all right how does
that look all right this has changed the
date is now our index because we said
the index column should be the date and
let's just confirm that it's what we
want it to be how about the index it's a
date time index excellent it's managed
to parse those dates so our data frame
looks like that and now we can do a join
so this should be correct so we're going
to take the daily data which we had
before that's the coffee data we're
going to join it to the number of people
in the department in announcer join let
me show you what that looks like
and I can't do it twice so that looks
like that so on the end of August we had
12 people but we have no idea how many
coffees we were on the end of September
no idea how many coffees but we had 14
people and then first of October we
started recording coffees 3rd of October
without arguments it's running on the
index so because it's an outer join it's
so this and said that this doesn't exist
in my daily data so create a row that
has a bunch of Nan's in it and then from
the people data that's where I go the
index from put that in there good
question
so there is an excellent article on here
we go it's called merge join and
concatenate and it will run through
every possible example of how ever you
possibly want to join your data in every
different form it is incredibly
elaborate you can ignore the index you
can just shove columns on and don't
worry if they're aligned you can do all
sorts by group keys anyway the one thing
I want to do now though is I want to
interpolate over this members thing
because we have a bunch of Mane's which
we don't particularly like we want to
fill those in so we're going to say
daily data is daily data that
interpolate anything I want interpolate
sorry daily data let's just try
interpolate method is nearest
all right here's the head of our data
frame let me have a few more rows we had
a bunch of man's here but now they've
been filled out
they even fill out to 14 because on this
date there were 14 people here we didn't
know but the nearest is 14 here we
didn't know but the nearest is 14 so
we've interpolated by just pushing that
forward it didn't interpolate on these
three nuns because there's nothing above
it and it didn't interpolate on these
because these are this is a string okay
everyone happy with that that's just an
interpolate as we did before let's
create a column from the number of
coffees per person this is an important
question
so coffees per person is going to be
daily data adult coffees made today and
what am I going to do with that divided
by daily data can I do this daily data
divided by so coffees made today divided
by members which is the number of people
in my department and now we have a
coffees per person column and on this
Tuesday it was 2.4 on the Wednesday
seminar day for looking good and again
we can I can show you a few more rows
Thursday was exceptionally nasty and
then Saturday and Sunday we didn't have
that many coffees all right starting to
get close now let's plot it so daily
data coffees per person dot plots and ok
what is going on alright I'm going to
ask for a couple of a little bit of
input what is going on with all of this
up and down nonsense
so again it's not a discrete data
problem this is a weekend effect and I
what you're seeing is the drop at the
weekend and the raise during the week
it's hard to see but that's what it is
what about here
so is it vacations is it market days is
it that the machine is broken
sadly this occurred to us a few times
and we were all very desperate by the
end of it but I have that data for you
so let's use read CSV to figure out data
about coffee status and I'm gonna read
the full instructions this time so parse
dates so I'm gonna pass an index call it
is again the date and I'm going to parse
dates it's true what does that look like
first dates
alright status is okay on those first
five days well that's great
but that doesn't tell us much what are
the values in this column well we can
use machine status dot status that is
the series remember and we can do a
value counts on that so there are only
two statuses okay and broken it could
also be a little crying face but 88 days
the machine is broken let's pull up that
I want to see when things break I'm
going to do a little trick I'm gonna say
numerical status is the machine status
adult status equals okay what is this
statement doing
see Rosen wants trues and falses this is
going to say for every row when the
status is okay on that row return true
and otherwise return false
and fortunately trues and falses zeros
and ones can be plotted as zeros and
ones and so here we have over time
because our index is at time date time
index we have one it was okay it was
okay it was okay it broke for a little
bit it was okay it broke it came back
for a few days it broke again I remember
that time it was very sad all right we
have this plot let's join it to our
growing data set so let's say daily data
is daily data drawing on machine status
it should be as easy as that great so
here's our status
and let's bring in that numerical
representation of trues and falses
rather than okay and broken so I'm going
to say daily data dot status is equal to
okay same thing we did to create a
series but now I'm just putting it
straight into a column true true true
true we have a false here because we
didn't have an entry on this date and
that's okay what we can do now though is
we can plot both of those things on the
same chart so this is called daily data
I'm going to take daily data and I'm
just gonna plot it as is and actually
I'm going to plot both columns because
here I have overpowering everything is
the number of coffees made to date how
do I select two columns I pass a list to
the index so I'm gonna pass status and
coffees made today all right
plotting status didn't help because it
was okay and broken but what if I pass
the numerical status
let me go and do daily data numerical
status I'm going to times you by a
hundred all right that looks better
all right so whenever this blue line
crashes down the machine is broken and
we can see that coincides spectacularly
with these moments where people didn't
drink coffee so we're happy with that
and that is due to us interpolating on
daily basis so the diff is is not zero
because by the time I started measuring
again the Machine had been back and some
coffees had been drunk and we spread
that diff out across those days all
right
strong weekend effect didn't like it why
don't we resample that when we say daily
data so weekly data is going to be the
daily data a dot I'm going to resample
Dalene resample weekly now and remember
resampling weekly is going to say create
a bin for every week every data point
that fold within a week group it into
that bin and then I'm going to take the
mean of all of those points that fall
into those weekly bins and then I can
say weekly data dot plot and I'm going
to plot again coffees made today and
miracles status so that's that data
frame and I'm going to plot it
all right so blue is our coffees made
and it's much smoother than it was now
I'm gonna ask you to squint a little bit
and say that Oh across time here was
fairly constant maybe a little bit of
like the post-christmas rush to get some
papers out and then what's this dip here
this dip happens during the summer
months
that's conference season that's it's too
nice to be working on outside and then
these Crashers they've smoothed out a
little bit because we've averaged those
two we've made those weekly bins but
they still coincide very very well with
where those coffees are not at the usual
level so just to wrap up here what have
we achieved today well we started by
cleaning the data sets so we cast
columns that were in correct types to
their correct types we dropped some rows
with no data and then we truncated the
time series when things got a bit weird
and people stopped spinning data we
explored the contributions so we
discovered who contributed to the data
set how many people by how much and we
established when on which days of the
weeks where those contributions made we
explored the time series by resampling
to a daily basis we interpolated over
those missing values to figure out what
those values should be we discovered on
what days of the week coffee was
primarily popular and that was on
Wednesday for the seminars we joined the
data set to others and that's always
half the battle anyway and then we
derive some new column from existing
ones we smoothed it out by down sampling
and so the insights we got out of this
was they weren't that many people
contributing to this data set it was
nine but given that on most days we had
maybe 12 13 14 people in the department
that's pretty good participation
contributions were lacking at the
weekends not because nobody was at the
office Monday's had the most
contributions and seminar Wednesday is a
strong driver of coffee consumption
makes sense periods of low coffee
drinking they matched up with peers when
the machine was broken and there was a
dip in the summer months as people were
away so I'm just gonna wrap it up there
and take any questions you might have
thank you
you